victor robert est ce que vous savez
qu'il ya fida turner oui c'est qui c'est
une candidate étude est la raison bleus
vous avez été la belle fille de tina
turner seulement non non c'est comme on
voit avant tout j'ai fait beaucoup de
choses chanteur compositeur d'accord et
je travaille
j'imagine m6 m'a découvert grâce à vous
on va les applaudir et puis surtout
cyril pour être là ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
wave machines paul billes espèce de gros
porc jean-claude la gauche qui chantent
club on applaudit jean claude van damme
c'était une expérience fantastique on a
fait quatre points huit de royal monceau
on a tout cassé sur m6 d'ailleurs après
moignard vous savez j'ai lancé la mode
des gens qui se barre du plateau quand
même mais c'est qui ça n'est pas reconnu
mais non j'ai du mal à me voir j'adore
alors enlevé la jeune femme lundi à
bercy
je suis en pleine bourre et le public
[Rires]
il touche pas à mon cul ce soir j'étais
88 sur m6 ce record d'audience de 14.8
partout alors et qui l'ont goode a
évidemment les cuisiniers personnelle et
vous afida vous aimez cuisiner que
j'avais monté un dîner presque parfait
voilà vous avez été payé pour un clip
parce que parfois beaucoup d'argent
après moi y'a plus rien ils sont passés
sur w9 j'ai fait trois points 9 ha ha ha
ha
j'ai gardé beaucoup de respect et donc
comme elle a des ministres mais vraiment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il atteindra un caillou la france
merci à vous ça vous fait quelque chose
quand vous voyez ça ouais c'est vrai
vous êtes ému ouais ouvrez capois 2 et
johnny je sais que nous entende de
l'autre n'a je suis très spirituelle et
j'espère que tes enfants seront pas
laissés dans dénouement à l'offre du
numéro unique de m pour être présent à
mon anniversaire à los angeles est
vraiment j'espère qu'on va tous
applaudir johnny bah oui
[Applaudissements]
déficit dans le dénuement dénuement
excusez-moi j'ai quand même un
basketteur vous savez d'ailleurs ils ont
fait 4.2 est sélectionné il ya fida
turner ça va hâter siens de l'ému elle
en train de mourir ça va est vrai bien
mais ça ne m'arrivera gré des annonces
j'aimerais pas du tout hein pas du tout
donc on peut bosser là bas le nom de
remettre une boucle d'oreille et j'adore
ces connards qui souffrent on va
l'applaudir à lehman a les cannes lions
[Applaudissements]
aussi bon avis vaut avis
[Musique]
je sais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui